alrighty so let's actually get to what
meghan markle and uh and prince harry
actually said because i mean what
difficult lives they lead it it is one
of the saddest stories i've ever heard
i mean a prince grew up a prince was
shielded from his own idiocy for
literally years
remember prince harry was a guy who just
back in 2005
dressed up in like a full-on nazi
uniform at a halloween party
right so like ralph northam would just
never happened right
it's pretty incredible how um how that
guy is now
captain woke so that's exciting stuff
repentance is possible people all you
have to do is take your entire family
and just toss them under the bus
and meanwhile megan what a victim what
uh i mean
what a difficult life she has led i i
can't speak
enough about what a heroin she is i mean
just the amount of heroism that she
displayed by going on oprah and ripping
on her in-laws family for
for fame and fortune i i mean truly
incredible stuff
she is she what it's tough it's tough i
mean so many tough things have happened
to meghan markle like one time kate
middleton taught her to curtsy
or print harry taught prince harry
taught her to curtsy right before she
met the queen you know it's just
because she was an ignorant american you
see and then she was ushered into the
halls
but then she she saw the flaws in the
royal family in a way no one else could
because she'd experienced american-style
racism so she was shocked to see it
in the halls of royalty that's it by the
way
netflix movie coming out in a year watch
starring them bro
probably right well maybe i don't know
maybe she'll recast herself but i don't
know maybe she like seeing herself on
film who the hell knows in any case here
she was explaining
you know the prince harry taught her to
curtsy she was just
a little down-home girl from from from
america
and she came in and she had she had to
learn the ways
of the royals but only she was able to
identify their deepest
secret flaw
here we go with oprah harry and i are in
the car and
he says okay well my grandmother's there
so you're going to meet her oh great
i love grandpa i loved my grandmother i
used to take care of my grandma this is
great he goes
right do you know how to curtsy what
he said do you know how to curtsy now i
thought genuinely that that was what
happens
outside yeah i thought that was part of
the fanfare or
i don't think that's what happens inside
and i said but it's your grandmother he
goes
it's the queen wow and that was really
the first moment that the penny dropped
oh my god she never realized she was
supposed to curtsy before the queen
um so that's what a difficult
i mean how difficult must that have been
to have to curtsy before the queen of
england
and my god how humiliating you know like
every other human who curses before the
queen of england or bows before the
queen of england
can't believe it just just crazy crazy
crazy stuff and that's when the penny
dropped and she was about to learn of
the predictions of the royals
by the way it's not all on meghan markle
harry's the actual villain of this piece
okay harry grew up with these people
and now he's just dumping all over his
entire family harry is a bag of garbage
harry is terrible
harry was captain uh captain i'm gonna
dress up however i wanna dress up i'm
gonna go to las vegas and get naked and
smoke pot on the basis of my royal
heritage
and then he's like and you know what i'm
gonna do now i'm gonna take my entire
family i'm just gonna drive up this bus
over them back up the bus over them
because
my wife wants to be a famous actress and
wasn't very good in suits now she wants
it so i'm going to go right on
the real villain here is not even megan
megan is whatever megan is
harry is the one who's the villain it's
his family right so
whatever i think i'm making i think
twice as badly of of harry okay so
then meghan markle starts talking about
how
difficult she starts talking about how
racist everyone was and she relates a
conversation
in which apparently somebody asked how
dark her son's skin would be
now this would be an excellent time for
oprah being the interviewer to ask okay
can you name a name
i mean that would be the if someone says
something as overtly racist as
how dark is your son's skin going to be
first of all what kind of stupid
i'm just gonna say i don't believe that
happened i don't think that happened
honest to god i don't think it happened
the reason i don't think that happened
is because no one says anything like
that that's a ridiculous question
how dark is your son's skin gonna be
like
beyond like the racism of it the actual
stupidity like the human stupidity
of having to ask that question do you
not
know what biracial children look like
like that's a what
because i don't believe this for a
second but here she is saying anything i
don't plus she's a
maybe it's true and she's such a bad
actress that i can't even tell that it's
true that's possible too here is megan
markel
in those months when i was pregnant all
around this same time
so we have in tandem the conversation of
he won't be
given security it's not going to be
given a title
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what cut away to oprah looking all
shocked
um yeah um
and then of course she she connects the
fact that that harry who
is like ninth in line for the throne at
this point that harry is not gonna get
the security he's not gonna get all this
stuff and
and again data i believe at this point
they'd already decided they want to move
to america
that that was going to be the basis for
that was going to be the basis
it was all about skin color of course
this is all about the
[Applause]
acism okay so she continues
along these lines and then she says that
she wanted to commit suicide
and the royal family would not get her
the mental help that she required
okay now again i don't know the truth or
falsehood of any of these statements i
do know that once you
claim that you were suicidal that you
had suicidal ideation
then people generally should not
question that so
i will assume that this is true i also
will assume that
i have no idea what anybody else did
around her because i don't think that
she's a credible source about anything
other than her own feelings
i think most people are credible sources
on their own feelings but people tend
not to be credible sources when they're
when their self-interest is at stake
here's meghan markle then
trying to impute to the royal family a
lack of care for her suicidal ideation
which is a hell of an accusation to make
look i was really ashamed to say it at
the time
and a shame to have to admit it to harry
especially
um because i know how much loss he
suffered
but i knew that if i didn't say it
that i would do it and i just didn't
i just didn't want to be alive anymore
okay and then what she says is that she
went to the institution and they were
like
you can't get outside help because if
you get outside help then that is going
to become
a story in and of itself well okay first
of all meghan markle was a story
from like the day that you joined the
royal family because you started
lecturing everybody inside
the palace about race i mean she was in
the tabloids every single day
so that's number one number two if you
think there aren't healthcare workers on
staff at the palace
i have doubts we'll get some more on
this in just one second first
let us talk about a simple truth a lot
is happening at that front door
it's never been more important to see
who is there or what is happening that
is why now is the perfect time to
upgrade your doorstep with a ring
video doorbell with ring you can see and
speak to whomever is at your door from
anywhere
right on your phone so you'll never miss
a visitor whether it's your neighbor
your dinner your groceries or
you can keep those packages and
deliveries safe as well with motion
detection you get notified even if they
don't ring the doorbell if somebody
stops by or something is going on
ring lets you know this is how i keep an
eye on my kids i have three kids they're
all moving now the baby is crawling
around this means i cannot keep track of
all three of them at the same time i
only have two eyes and they have to be
focused in the same direction there's no
way for me to just be able to focus
in several different places at once
no matter your home ring has everything
you need to protect it see and speak
to whoever is at your door from anywhere
with video doorbells keep an eye on
every corner of your house with easy to
install indoor and outdoor cams protect
your whole home with ring alarm a
powerful affordable
whole home security system you can
easily install yourself right now got a
special offer on the ring welcome kit at
ring.com
ben shapiro it comes with the ring video
doorbell 3 and the chime pro
the perfect way to upgrade your front
door and start your ring experience so
head on over to ring.com ben shapiro
that is ring.com
ben shapiro okay so i'm not going to
question her suicidal ideation
i am going to question the story because
again no names no specifics it is all
these broad allegations that are being
made and in fact
post interview apparently harry has now
come out he says you know who it wasn't
it wasn't elizabeth and it wasn't it
wasn't prince philip it wasn't any of
the people who people actually care
about from the royal family
but they won't name names okay so this
was pretty fun
at a certain point oprah actually asked
megan if she left the royal family to
brand build
and megan is like no no no no no no
of course not here she was there are
even stories that
you knew all along that this was gonna
happen you went through the whole
process
and it was all intentional to
build your brand can you imagine how
little sense that makes
i left my career my life i left
everything because i love him
right and our plan was to do this
forever our plan for me i mean i wrote
letters to his family when i got there
saying i am dedicated to this
i'm here for you use me as you'd like
there was no
guidance as well right there were
certain things that you couldn't do but
you know unlike what you see in the
movies there's no class on how to
how to speak how to cross your legs how
to be
royal there's none of that training that
might exist for other members
of the family that was okay okay okay
okay the beginning
the beginning part of that that's
hysterically funny i'm sorry that's just
from any angle that is super funny
so oprah's like so did you like join the
royal family and then you knew that you
were gonna build your career that way
and
she's like can you imagine can i left my
career
as a second-rate actress in a third-tier
part
on suits to be a princess and somebody
would suggest
that i did that for career purposes no i
did it cause i love this dumbass over
here
it's gonna love the guy sitting next to
me this guy
right here prince harry captain lovable
love that guy
i mean i left a job on suits on suits
mm-hmm
i'm sure it was all pure love listen
maybe they love each other that's fine
sure all right sure i'm i'm sure career
had nothing to do
like i'm sorry that's i left my job on
suits
and you're suggesting that maybe
becoming a princess was a career move
a little a little i'm suggesting
because um that is not a horizontal move
right there
i'm sorry when you think of like
horizontal versus vertical career moves
across on suits to princess is that a
horizontal move
i'm gonna go no on that one no
okay but again markle is not the actual
villain of this piece
meghan markle is whatever megan markle
is okay
prince harry's the villain of the piece
he knows all the members of his family
he's the one who has decided that he is
going to
go along with whatever his wife wants to
do here and he's going to say terrible
terrible things about his family
and he's going to prove that he is
morally superior to his family
so for example prince harry he says that
he is free
his brother and his father they are
trapped but he he
is so free now he's free like a bird and
he is free to speak
about the evils of his own family first
of all people who dump on their own
families typically ask
jackasses like not good people here's
prince harry
you know but i'm i'm free they're
trapped i'm here with you oprah
with you here's prince harry who again
worse than meghan markle
please explain how you prince harry
raised in a palace
in a life of privilege literally a
prince
how you were trapped trapped within the
system
like the rest of my family are my father
and my brother
they are trapped they don't get to leave
and i have huge compassion for that wow
i mean
they don't get to leave they're trapped
but i i am free here with you oprah
and uh and you know i got cut off from
the royal fortune i only ha
i could only live on my mother's 25
million endowment
that's really what they said 25 million
okay so there's an actual deeper
underlying thing that's going on here
and that has to do with racism and
colonialism there's been this move in
britain to do sort of what you've seen
in the united states which is the entire
history of britain is about colonialism
and racism and brutality
in the same way that the entire history
of america is about racism and
colonialism and brutality right this is
all tied in
and prince harry backs that to the hilt
so he starts talking about how
he's done the work right other members
of the world they didn't do the work
he says racism drove him out of britain
it was the tabloids and there was
racism that drove him out of britain and
then he says quote i've spent many years
doing the work
and doing my own learning but then my
upbringing and the system in which i was
brought up
and in which i've been exposed to i
wasn't aware of it to start with but by
god
it doesn't take very long to suddenly
become aware of it it takes living in
her shoes
for a day or those first eight days to
see where it was gonna go and how far
they were gonna take it and get away
with it
yes yes now he he's gonna lecture the
royal family on their race
again the only reason he's a relevant
figure is because this is a relevant
institution but this is an attempt to
tear down the institution so let's be
clear about what this is okay at least
by prince harry
and you know i think that markle is just
bringing american brand racial politics
to britain and it's kind of it's kind of
an ugly site it is kind of
especially if you're not willing to name
names because let's be real about this
if somebody said that as an employee of
the royal family and they she named the
name they'd be fired
right now there's an investigation going
on into meghan markle right not into the
royal family it's going on into meghan
markle and how she treated the employees
and the staff
over there the reason this has some
deeper significance though
truly is because what everybody
recognizes that the british monarchy
being
essentially just a facade at this point
that it really doesn't have any
institutional power
all it is is just a face for the history
of britain and when harry and megan
make the case that the british monarchy
is rife with colonialism and racism
that they have not moved beyond any of
that that there is still this deep
systemic racism
that is inherent in the most beloved
part of the british government namely
the figurehead
what they're really saying is that all
of british history and really british
society
is infused with the same sort of
systemic racism they accuse america of
having as well
that's what this is all about i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the ben shapiro
show if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content